all right we're back with Governor Cuomo
can I say that I am a homosexual yep
Ellen DeGeneres went there while video
chatting with New York Governor Andrew
Cuomo on Monday show you know that
that's going around that people are
saying their Cuomo sexuals yeah I think
that's a good thing I don't think it's a
bad thing it's not a bad thing people
are in love you and if you're a Cuomo
sexual to the governor's response will
make you love him even more
it started with Trevor Noah and but not
only but but it includes your brother
quit it Chris I you're you're both
Cuomo's I enjoy both of you very much
yes but you enjoy me more didn't you say
that earlier yes yes yes I can say that
right now because I'm talking to you but
then when I'll talk to him I'll say he's
my favorite it's like I know you have
this competition with you know who the
mother loves more and I understand all
that but you're both charming you're
both adorable let's watch that one more
time yes but you enjoy me more didn't
you say that earlier yes yes the term
Cuomo sexual refers to Andrew and his
brother CNN anchor Chris Cuomo's adoring
new fans there's a group of women who
came out and they said we we're falling
in love with Cuomo and I said well yeah
everyone everyone should we have
homosexual in that way I don't miss a
press conference when Cuomo's on I'm I
turn I'm like got to go see my celebrity
crush right now sorry these feelings are
perfectly natural many Americans
experience moments of being at least
Andrew curious if not fully Cuomo sexual
Andrew and Chris have captured many
hearts with their on-air sparring over
the last few weeks amid the corona virus
pandemic I'm proud of what you're doing
I know you're working hard for your
state but no matter how hard you're
working there's always time to call mom
she wants to hear from you just so you
know yeah I called mom I called mom just
came on this show by the way she said I
was her favorite she never said good
news is she said you were her second
favorite second favorite son Christopher
Chris hosted Cuomo primetime throughout
his battle with Kovac 19
and when Ellen asked Andrew if his
little brothers diagnosis brought them
even closer
well his response was everything no you
can't be closer than I am with my
brother Chris we have been all our lives
he's my best friend but he is a very
special relationship I just felt bad
during that whole coronavirus thing oh
there's more
look talk about guts he the day he got
diagnosed with it he went on air that
night and that took real guts you know I
don't care how strong you are they
called you up and they say you tested
positive for coronavirus you have to
have some butterflies in your stomach
and he went right on the air that night
and I think he did a great public
service because he he shared it with
people
he took the mystery off it and he showed
what it was like every step of the way
and we actually had some fun with it
so it was it all worked chris has since
recovered but his wife Christina and
their 14 year old son also went on to
test positive for the virus ET video
chatted with Christina earlier this
month
and she had this to say about her
husband and brother-in-law's
relationship yeah they're always taking
digs at each other and it's hilarious
and it always provides for entertainment
at family functions and they love each
other to death I mean Andrew really
helped raise Chris so Chris learned a
lot from him and you know they kind of
finish each other sentences and you know
they you know they ingest and it's it's
provides for a lot of entertainment it's
really nice but they're sharing it with
everyone else now so it goes you know a
little relief from their anxiety through
some humor what's more the 50 year old
wellness expert says she's totally
embracing the Cuomo sexual trend and the
Cuomo sectional t-shirts yeah they're
hilarious I love them I have someone
sending me a sweater that says that and
then I had I mean it then we should get
some masks
right there you go and send my love to
your little brother and tell him I'm
very happy he's feeling better and my
love to the family thank you thank you
Ron thank you very much pleasure to be
with you all right
thanks nice to be with you too and my
love to the boyfriend stop there
[Music]